Well, ladies and gentlemen,
one thing that I've learned
from The Slow Mo Guys
is that I thoroughly
enjoy watching Dan get hit
in the face with stuff.
Dan, How do you feel about that?
I really enjoy it.
Yeah.
I actually like it so much,
it makes me want to celebrate
every time that it happens.
So I thought today kill
two birds with one stone,
and injure Dan and
celebrate in the same go.
Now, one thing I'm worried
about is this cork is gonna fire
out of this at a high speed.
High speed.
And what I'm worried about
is the cork might bounce
off your head and hit
me in the eyes. So...
That would be terrible.
What I'm gonna do is
wear some safety goggles
to protect my eyes from this.
Do I get any?
You want some as well?
Yeah.
Fair one.
There you go.
Cheers.
Let's get on with it.
Sweet.
Oh!
Oh no!
Whoa!
Oh no.
Oh!
Oh
That's really distracting
by side of my face.
Oh!
Ah!
Geez.
Did I do the face?
Oh!
The side of the jawbone.
Ah!
Now upon review,
it appears that the cork hit right here
Ah!
On the side of the goggles so...
Does that mean we have to do it again?
It does.
Thankfully we do have backups.
I'm gonna-
Yep, carry on.
And you might want to kill
some of the pain with that.
So this one I'm gonna
try and aim a bit lower.
Right in your chops.
Cheers.
Here we go.
The tension is definitely, I like it.
Oh crap.
Oh, he's shaking it.
Oh God.
Ah!
Oh!
Right on the cheek hole.
Ah.
How do you get it on my bone every time?
I like to do everything in threes.
So we did get a third.
I know I already nailed
his cheek right there.
But let's go for another one, why not?
Ah!
Stop, it's so bloody tense!
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Oh!
Ah!
How was that then?
Yeah really nice, liked it.
So on these
Tasty.
Could you like re-shake
them to get a bit of?
Oh!
Fuck!
Still tastes good.
Horrible.
Cheers for that.